HIT THE OUTSIDE OF THE NET!
GETS A SECOND ATTEMPT.
THE
NEGOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIS TEAMMATE.
A NICE LITTLE PUSH THAT
TOWARDS THE DEFENDER AND MU
>> Bob: HE GIVES A A BY HIMSELF
A NEUTRAL ZONE STEAL AND A
SHORTHANDED GOAL  TO TIE
. THAT ALLOWS HIM TO PRETTY
MUCH PUT IT ANYWHERE HE W
GAPING UP THE SHORT SIDE. AGAIN
WE START OFF IN THE SECOND
THEY MOVE IN.
CAN SE
THEY RUSH ON THE WASHINGTON
CAPITALS GOAL.
NIGHT!
TO HIGH.
YOU CAN SEE THE AVALANCHE ARE
BACK
I WONDER IF HE WILL GET MORE
ICE TIME  PUT IN.
HE HAS HIS GOAL BACKWARDS.
THAT HIT THE POST.
HE TAKES HIM BEHIND THE NET.
BILL CONTROLLED BY COLORADO.
3:060, COLORADO PULLS OUT
EVERYTHING.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S GOING TO
COME DOWN THE MIMITHE FIRSTGOAL
>>